time crystals
yeah um what are they these things are
it's a very beautiful idea when we start
to um
treat space and time as
similar frameworks yes right physical
phenomena right that's what motivated it
what are first of all what are crystals
yeah and what time crystals
okay so crystals are orderly
arrangements
of atoms in space and
many materials if you cool them down
gently
will form crystals and so we say
that that's uh a spun a state of matter
that forms spontaneously
and uh an important feature of that
state of matter
is that the end result the crystal
has less symmetry than
the equations that give rise to the
crystal so
the equations the basic equations of
physics uh
are the same if you uh move a little bit
so you can move they're homogeneous but
crystals aren't the atoms are in
particular place so
they have less symmetry uh
and time crystals are the same thing in
time basically
you you but of course it's not so it's
not positions of atoms
but it's ordering uh orderly behavior
uh that certain states of matter
uh will arrange themselves into
spontaneously
if you do them if you if you treat them
gently and let them do what they want to
do but in
repeat in that same way indefinitely
that's the crystalline form you could
also have
uh uh time liquids or you can have all
kinds of
other states of matter you don't have
space-time crystals where
the pattern only repeats if uh with each
step of time you also move it a certain
a certain direction in space so so yeah
so but it's so
it's basically it's states of matter
that uh oh base
that display structure in time
spontaneously
so here's here's the difference when it
happens in time
uh it sure looks a lot like its motion
and if it repeats indefinitely it sure
looks a lot like perpetual motion yeah
like uh looks like free lunch
i was told that there's no such thing as
free lunch does
does this violate laws of thermodynamics
uh
no but it requires a critical
examination of the
laws of thermodynamics i mean let me let
me say on background that the laws of
thermodynamics are not
the not fundamental laws of physics
there are things we prove
under certain circumstances emerge from
the fundamental laws of physics
right they're not we don't posit them
separately they're
meant to be deduced and they can be
deduced under limited circumstances but
not necessarily
universally and we found finding some of
the subtleties and
sort of accept edge cases uh where they
don't
apply in a straightforward way
and this is one uh so
time crystals do obey do have this
structure in time but it's not a free
lunch
because although in a sense things are
moving
uh they're they're already doing what
they want to do they're
in there so if if you want to extract
energy from it
you're going to be foiled because
there's no spare energy
there you uh it's
so you you can add energy to it and kind
of disturb it
but but you can't extract energy
from this motion because it's gonna it
wants to do that's the lowest energy
configuration that there is so you you
can't get further energy out of it so in
theory i guess
perpetual motion you would be able to
extract energy from it
yeah if such a thing was to be created
you can then
milk it for energy well what's the
what's usually
meant in the literature of perpetual
motion
is a kind of macroscopic motion
that you could extract energy from and
and somehow
it would crank back up right that's
that's not the case here if you want to
extract
energy this motion is
is not something you can extract energy
from if you
intervene in the behavior you can
uh change it but only by injecting
energy not not by taking away energy
you